MALE SPEAKER: Almost there.
One hour until social time.
But before that,
it's social time.
I'm very pleased to announce
Ade Oshineye to the stage.
I've worked with him for
the last three years,
and he's given me a lot
of insights into developer
experience, crafting
good software.
Today, he's going to talk to
you about growing with Google.
Ade.
ADE OSHINEYE: Sorry about this.
Turns out I'm a bit lost.
While we're waiting
for the slides
to catch up, while
I fiddle with this,
I'm going to talk to you
about Grow with Google (+).
The parentheses are deliberate.
So I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
I've actually been here longer
than everybody in the room.
I've been at Google forever.
But I thought I
would take a moment
to find out a little
bit about you.
Because part of
the job of advocate
is about listening to
what you guys want.
I thought we'd try a
little interaction.
Can you stand up, please?
OK.
So if you've never played
Flappy Bird, sit down.
Stay standing.
Anybody who's got a high
score that's higher than five,
stay standing.
Anybody whose high score
is less than five, sit.
Less than 15?
Less than 25?
Less than 40?
Less than 60?
Just take a moment.
This is the hard core.
OK, less than 100.
Wait, wait, wait, less than 200.
Ah, it gets interesting.
OK, we're down to the final two.
OK, less than 300.
Less than 350.
OK, less than 400?
Now he has to go.
So I believe he's the king.
So if you follow him on
Google+ and play Flappy Bird,
you'll see his
high score is 358.
356, sorry.
There's actually
somebody I know who
has a better score than him.
AUDIENCE: What device was it?
ADE OSHINEYE: Rich, what
device were you playing on?
AUDIENCE: Nexus 5.
ADE OSHINEYE: Nexus 5.
AUDIENCE: You have to
find the cheat code.
ADE OSHINEYE:
There's a cheat code?
AUDIENCE: Must have
to get that score.
ADE OSHINEYE: No, it's
called not having a life.
It's a very popular cheat code.
My score is 64.
I did that this morning.
So we've now learned a
little bit about you.
Let's talk a little
bit about Google.
OK, so I'm here to talk to you
about the Google+ platform.
So up until the end of March,
I am a developer advocate
on Google+.
From April, we're changing
things a little bit.
We're moving away from this
focus on specific platforms,
specific products, and trying
to think about the world the way
you see it.
And the way you tend to
see it is you see Google
as one company, one service.
You don't really care
about our org chart.
You want to think about,
I want to use some service
from Google, and just
be able to just use it.
You don't want to get
told, oh, I'm sorry,
that's not my department.
You don't want to be
told, oh, I'm sorry,
that's not managed over here.
Please talk to the person in the
right department in New York.
Oh, you're not in New York?
That's unfortunate.
You'd like a more
holistic organization,
and one of the things we're
trying to do is to get there.
One of the first things we did
as part of that is we set up
Google+.
Part of this was to
have a unified account
system for all Google users.
For example, I'll give
you something interesting
you may not know.
On the third floor
of this building,
we have a YouTube studio
and a lot of YouTube people.
And it was great.
We'd bring in
YouTube celebrities,
and every now and again,
somebody would say, hey,
do you know Google is
in the same building?
And the YouTube guys
would go, well, yeah.
They own us.
And then YouTube celebrities
would say, no way.
We'd say, no, really.
It happened several years ago.
And it turns out
people didn't know.
One of the things we've been
doing with Google+ is trying
to say, can we unify the
experience of Google so that
if you use any of our services,
you have access to all of them
as an end user?
Also, how do we make
sure that if you
want to use one of our
services or APIs or libraries,
you should be able to use
that in any language--
except Perl, because we
can't get volunteers.
The idea is that you
should be able to use
it web, iOS, Android,
it shouldn't matter.
You should have access to it.
So we're thinking about taking
the different platforms we've
got and making
them work together
so that we don't have
a Play console which
is different from the
Google API console, which
is different to how
YouTube does things.
We want to fix that.
We want to simplify this.
Part of this is also
thinking about metrics,
trying to change what we do so
it makes more sense for you.
So let's try a little survey.
When you guys are choosing
which games to build,
working your games, putting
your games into production,
what are the metrics you use?
So shout out-- what
kind of metrics
do you guys use to
measure the success
or failure of your games?
Retention, anything else?
Up down?
Virality.
Anything else?
Installs.
Active users.
Cold hard cash.
That's a good metric.
It's hard to game that metric.
The point is, there's lots
and lots of these metrics,
and as a platform, we need
to be asking ourselves,
how do we help you
optimize these metrics?
How do we help you make
sure that these numbers
go up and to the right?
Especially that cold
hard cash number.
So what I'm going to do is talk
about the four sets of metrics
that we're currently
particularly focused on.
Reach, user acquisition and
conversion, user engagement
retention, and re-engagement.
I'm just going to skim
this because we only
have about 25 minutes left.
But I just want to give you
a brief overview of some
of the tools that are available
in Google+ and the way it hooks
into the rest of Google
that you can take advantage
of to optimize these metrics
or these sets of metrics.
Let's start with reach.
So you build something,
and we'd like
you to reach as many
people as possible with it.
Well, for reach,
you've got to go
for the biggest hammer we have.
It's a little site
called google.com.
You may have heard of it.
The first and
fundamental problem
you're going to have as a
game developer is nobody's
heard of you.
Or they've heard of
you, but they have not
heard of your new game.
So for example, who
here can tell me
all the Angry Birds games and
the difference between them
all?
Can you?
AUDIENCE: I can.
ADE OSHINEYE: Really?
OK, what's Angry Birds Stars?
AUDIENCE: There is no
such thing as Stars.
Star Wars, maybe?
ADE OSHINEYE: See, I'm confused.
My point is, when
I go to google.com,
I'm going to type Angry Birds
Stars, and it's going to say,
you didn't mean that.
You meant Angry Birds Star Wars.
But my friend told
me Angry Birds Stars,
and who am I going to believe?
You or the guy in the pub?
So if you're going
to be in search,
you've got to be
thinking, how do I
make sure I rank for my name?
How do I rank for common
misspellings of my name?
Because again,
your users probably
don't spend their time obsessing
about the latest releases
you've done, even if you are as
famous as the Angry Birds guys.
They even have branded hoodies.
First thing you've
got to be thinking
is, are you doing a
good job with SEO?
Do you have a
website for your game
where people can actually
discover you through search?
One of the best ones in the
world, the Play Store search
is not as good as
google.com's search.
It's getting better, but this
is still one of the best places
to get discovered.
So obviously you can do things
like have a Google+ page
to make it easier for them
to discover your brand
or your game.
But again, it means that when
they type your name in or they
type a horrible misspelling
of your name-- for example,
Ruzzle is how many z's?
Again, as a user, I don't care.
I just type some
approximation to search,
and search points me
in the right direction.
The point is, search-- and
of course, advertising--
are great ways to let
people get maximum reach.
They are ways where
people can discover you.
So they've discovered you.
Now this could mean they've
discovered you through the Play
Store, or it could mean
they've discovered you
because they went
to your website.
And of course, you have
a link to the Play Store
so they can install your game.
OK Yes?
You guys aren't one
of those people who's
got a website that doesn't
actually tell people
how to get a hold of your game?
Because that's embarrassing.
All right, so the
user's found you.
You need to convert them.
So conversion could be as simple
as they click on the link,
they get taken to
the Play Store.
Great.
If you've got a game that spans
multiple platforms or spans
the web, and Android
and iOS, as well,
one of things we have with
Google+ sign in is a feature
where they can
sign in on the web,
and then we can push
the app, the game,
to their devices over the air
so that you can convert them
on the web, and they've got the
game installed on their device.
The point is, if the user signs
in on the web or on Android,
they should be
signed in everywhere.
That means when
I pick up-- let's
say I buy a new tablet
like the new HTC One,
or a really ridiculously big
phone like the new HTC One--
it's so big, it's
easy to confuse
with a tablet-- I buy that.
I install your game.
I sign in.
I should resume from
where I started,
from where I was last
time on my other devices.
So I shouldn't have to worry
about every time starting again
from scratch.
So when we think
about conversion,
conversion could be as
simple as getting the user
to create a stronger
bond with your game
because they've signed in,
they have a high score table,
things like that.
For traditional apps,
it tends to be all about
can they get installed
from the web.
So this is Deezer.
They're a French company.
This is what the install
process looks like.
As you can see, it's just a
standard Google Play widget,
but they get to pick devices.
Again, obviously, you'd prefer
people to just discover you
through the Play Store,
but there's this web thing.
I hear it's going to be big.
So it's a good place
to get discovered,
and it's a good place
to drive installs.
Again, it's a fairly easy
thing to do, especially
if you're a big enough
company or you are trying
to build a community
on your own site,
or you're trying to build
an engaging experience
on your own site.
Somehow, people have found you.
They've installed your game.
They've signed in.
How do you keep them?
Ideas?
How do you keep people coming
back to play your game?
AUDIENCE: Pay them.
ADE OSHINEYE: Pay them, OK.
What else?
New content?
AUDIENCE: Something
attractive to draw them back.
ADE OSHINEYE: OK, something
Rewards.
There's a lot of
things you can do.
But one of the
things we've added
is a little feature
called Incremental Auth.
And the reason we've added
this is because it turns out
lots of people use YouTube and
a lot of other Google services,
and sometimes you can use the
data in those other services
to make your experience
better, more enriching.
So for example, you can
ask them after they've
signed in-- so it's a separate
process-- you can say,
can we have access to
your YouTube account
because perhaps we'd like to
write YouTube videos to it?
So that when you have that
great, wonderful, perfect round
of Flappy Bird
when you get to 64,
you can actually
capture the recording
and share it on YouTube
so people can see
you didn't cheat.
If Rich had captured his
356 score with a video,
he could send that around
now to prove he didn't cheat.
But he didn't, so we have
to believe he's cheating.
Point being, this is a
separate section from sign in.
And you could pull in
any Google APIs this way.
So that means you could
do things like-- can we
capture screenshots and maybe
share them to Drive, or are
there things you
have in other Google
properties that we can
use to augment this game?
Typically, if it's a
music-related game,
one thing you can do is
with the user's permission,
go through their YouTube history
and use their musical tastes
to influence the
nature of the game.
The point is, from
the sign in flow,
you could either ask for a
wide range of Google APIs,
or you can ask for
them incrementally,
and use those to enrich
the experience of the game.
The point being, it
gives you an opportunity
to personalize the game so
that you can see your face,
your friends' faces, the
things that matter to you.
You've got a game.
You've got people,
they've signed in.
They've brought their
social graph across.
You've somehow made the
game engaging, enticing,
interesting, because
you've personalized
it using data you
have that's available
about them from the full
range of Google services.
How do I keep them engaged?
How do I retain them?
Well, if you've used any of the
Google Play games in the past,
you know that we have high
scores, we have leader boards.
One of the really
nice things you can do
that actually starts
to get very interesting
is when I share that high
score, what do I share?
Now, the typical
thing people do is
they share just a
little blob of text.
As you can see, I
scored zero points.
That's actually
unlocked an achievement.
But nothing stops them
from editing there,
cheating and saying yeah,
I scored 1,000 points,
except for the screen shot,
which keeps me honest.
The point being,
you can start to do
these kinds of
interesting things
to actually make the sharing
experience more compelling.
Because Flappy Bird is
actually a pretty OK game,
but what makes it great is
when you get a new high score
and you take that
screenshot, which
you have to do manually
in Flappy Bird,
and then you share it to
the stream to tell people,
look what I did.
And somebody else sends you back
a message a few minutes later
saying, look, I just
beat your score.
And that gets you to come back.
There's an authenticity that
comes from having the screen
shot, rather than me
claiming I got 1,000 points.
So that's a much
more powerful system.
So you have achievements,
but ultimately, the thing
that gets you to come back
is, I had a great experience.
Here's the proof of it, here's
the social proof of this.
And I share that with people I
know, and then they come back.
Because a lot of people will
try your game-- it's OK,
it's great-- and then they
get bored or life intervenes,
and then somebody
they know plays it,
and then they come back.
So Rich, for example,
has tried to quit
Flappy Bird on
multiple occasions.
And every time he does,
somebody beats his high score,
and he has to come back.
It's like in-- what's that
mafia film? "The Godfather"?
Just when you think you're
out, they pull you back in.
Speaking of which,
re-engagement.
Who here actually sends
re-engagement emails
in their games?
Hands up.
Nobody?
Come on, I play your games.
Who here sends re-engagement
notifications telling people,
you haven't played
our game for a week?
Please come back.
This is a picture my kids.
They need the money.
So everybody does this, or
if they're not doing this,
they're thinking
about doing this.
And the reason they do this
is because a person plays
the game, they get a certain
way in, they get bored
or they get stuck,
and they stop playing.
How do we re-engage them?
Well, you nag them.
You spam them.
And you hope they come back.
Does it work on you guys?
Who here actually gets
a re-engagement email,
they get a re-engagement
notification,
and then they say, oh well,
I'll play that game now.
That guy.
So spam him.
Because everybody
else finds it annoying
because you get an
email once a day.
So I have a service
called 750 Words,
and it emails me
each day to tell me
I should write 750 words.
I've learned to ignore it.
I have a Duolingo subscription.
It emails me every day to tell
me I should practice my French.
I've learned to ignore it.
That's because I'm a bad person.
However, I am not alone.
There are many bad
people on this planet.
There's about 7 billion of us.
And we've learned that
these emails telling
you to come back, these
notifications telling
us to come back, it's a machine
somewhere telling you you
should probably play
this game again.
It doesn't have any
meaning, it doesn't
have any emotional weight.
What does have emotional
weight is getting
a message from somebody you
know telling you something
has happened, something
worthwhile is going on.
So for example, here's a recipe
I shared on Google+ for honey
soy chicken.
Of course, I can't
cook because I
worked at Google for
nearly seven years.
So I make a post saying,
if only I could cook.
And hopefully, somebody I
know will click on that,
learn the recipe, and
then invite me around
because they made
this-- it could happen.
Here's a song.
By the way, who here has
heard the acoustic version
of Justin Bieber's "Boyfriend"?
It's actually pretty good.
I can say that because
this is all on the NDA.
But hey, I can share that song
and people can click on it
and they can listen to the song.
But the point is, I share this,
and people say, what the hell?
And they click on it,
because why would I say this?
And then they say, actually,
it's not that horrible.
And then they show it to
a few of their friends.
It's not that horrible,
the acoustic version.
And it spreads it that way.
This is how things like
Flappy Bird spreads.
And it's that
message that spreads.
It's the idea of somebody
actually saying this.
By the way, in this version,
this app, Soundwave, actually
created that message for me.
I had the option of whether I
wanted to edit or delete this.
I would never say,
"check out" this song.
I would say, "hey, give
this song a listen."
Point is, when you share what
we call an interactive post,
you get the call to
action button, which
says Listen here, Learn here.
You get a pre-field of text.
You can +Mention up to
10 of the user's friends.
So that's a notification the
user will see across any Google
product across all
of their devices.
But because it's a
human-mediated message,
they know it came from a person
and that person was involved.
For example, this is
an app called Fancy,
and they have a really
nice affiliate scheme
where you buy stuff from them.
It's a business model
where you give them money
and they give you stuff.
It's a Web 3.0 business model.
In this case, I'm sharing a
vintage Rolex Submariner watch.
It's ridiculously expensive.
As you can see, I've
hidden the amount of zeroes
because it goes off the edge.
It's like $30,000 for a watch.
But it's a really nice
watch, apparently.
So I share this to my stream.
And say Larry or Sergey was
following me and they saw this,
and they go, oh, that's
nice, and they click
Buy-- they would be
taken into the Fancy app.
If they didn't
have the Fancy app,
they would be taken
to the Play Store
on Android, the App Store
on iOS, to install the app.
So if you think about this
as if you were sharing
an interactive post for
a high score on a game,
the people who didn't have
the game when they clicked
on that button would be
taken through a process
to install the game
because somebody
they know has recommended this.
So in this case, let's say
Larry and Sergey get that watch
recommendation from
me because look,
I wear two Smartband things.
I must know about watches.
Fancy actually has
an affiliate model,
so if Larry and Sergey
bought 10 of these watches,
I get a small percentage.
It's unlikely to happen
because they'd probably
just buy the watch company.
I don't get a
percentage on that.
But the point
about this is, what
you have is a human who has
reached a particular place
within an app or a game,
has found some content
that they think will
resonate with their friends,
and you've been able to
nudge them to share that,
and then when those
friends see that message,
they click on the button.
They become an app
install for you.
So it's not just hey,
here's a cool thing.
It's here's a cool
thing and an action
you can perform
that will cause you
to install on iOS or Android.
Point being, people don't really
respond very well to messages
from machines, but they
from actual people.
My parents have nagged me
for 30-something years.
It still works.
Whereas in a few months,
I get trained very quickly
to ignore notifications from
certain games, certain apps.
The point being,
human communication--
having people be the one
to drive the sharing,
whether it's of a high
score of a particular level,
or if it's a screen shot or
a video of a particular piece
of a game, is very,
very powerful.
Because there's a unified
Google experience,
this spreads to wherever there
are people are using Google.
And the final piece
is that little site
called google.com
we talked about.
Now, when I share a message
or a screen shot or a video
or whatever through Google+ from
YouTube or within your game,
I've shared to specific circles.
When those people are doing
searches later on, if things
they search for match
the post I made,
even if it's a private post,
the Think or Search+ your world,
as you can see there, that
personalized search feature we
now have for users who are
signed in means that they will
see that private
post right here.
Remember earlier when I shared
that post about the Submariner
Rolex watch, and
it had the phrase,
if only I had a submarine?
Here it is in web search.
So the point driving the ad
is that users can discover you
through the Play Store.
They can also discover
you through web search.
The content you and
your users share out
from within your game, often the
YouTube videos of your games,
can be discovered again
by those same users
through general web search.
And they click on that,
they end up in that post,
there's that Call
to Action button.
They click on that, they've
now installed your game.
So you don't have
this trap where
you have to get
all the conversions
in the first few weeks.
You have content that lives
out for-- well, in this case,
37 minutes after
I made the post--
but theoretically, your content
can live for months and months,
and those people can still
be coming back into your game
months after the initial
flurry of traffic.
So there's a much
bigger opportunity here
to use all of Google's services
to drive growth for your games
and to think about reach
and conversion and all
of those things-- and of
course, cold hard cash.
Thank you very much.
Does anybody have any questions?
Or would you like to
throw cold hard cash?
That's also good.
OK, thank you very much.